Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday match 25th,
2019.
What's going on?
How are you?
Um,
I'm going to fucking great mood this Monday.
121 days.
No fucking booze.
On Wednesday,
I'll be a third through the year already.
33 fucking present.
33.5,
whatever the fuck you need.
33.3,
three,
repeating,
uh,
through the year.
Just like that.
I feel great.
You know,
it's funny,
it was,
um,
we had some people over here yesterday.
Um,
I got some family in town,
so we had a little cookout and uh,
you know,
I needed some space on this table so we can put perhaps some shit.
So I took all my bows and I just,
I brought it out of the kitchen.
I just took it upstairs and put it in the bedroom.
And um,
you know,
just so we have another area.
Pregnant was not the biggest fucking kitchen,
right?
So fucking little prep area to cook.
So I fucking last night I'm going to bed and my new thing,
I swear to God to go to sleep rather than they have three fucking scotches like
I used to is I actually read,
I swear to God,
I'm reading,
I'm sober and I'm reading how fucking funny is that?
So I uh,
yeah,
I finished this book on Bob Cousy and Bill Russell that I really enjoyed and I'm
going to give it to a buddy of mine cause I don't like keeping books.
They're fucking heavy.
They take up space and I always act like I'm going to go back and read them
again and I don't.
So,
um,
now I'm reading the,
uh,
the Beastie boy book,
a hardcover edition.
And as I was taking the plastic off,
I was thinking like,
is this going to affect the value of it?
And it's just like,
Bill,
when do you sell anything on Ebay?
Never.
Alright,
cool.
So I was reading that and all I had was my little reading light on at my bed and
I looked over and I had a bottle of the Yippy Kai.
Yay.
Right.
The Bourbon,
absolutely delicious.
Unopened.
Just sitting there and the way the light was hitting it and the way it was
passing through the bottle,
it literally looked like it.
Like,
like a sunrise.
Yeah.
And I would be lying to you if I didn't,
so to sit up in bed and just look at it for a hard 20 seconds.
MMM.
And I was just,
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That was like,
that looks fucking delicious.
But I didn't,
I bought,
I will tell you this,
I'm going to get it out of the bedroom though.
I don't need to be staring at that late at night,
you know,
while I need to do is have a tough day and then have those bottles looking at as
me sitting there like,
Hey,
bill will help you take the edge off.
Can I had one drink every 121 days?
That's not a bad thing.
You see is a little taste go on of it until that tasted,
um,
anyways,
uh,
plowing ahead.
So,
uh,
I'm going to get that shit out of there.
Um,
I also buy ordered a one of those pitch backs,
which I haven't had since I was a kid where you,
you know,
you,
it's,
you throw the ball,
it's like basically just like a net and it records Shay's back.
You can either get grounders fly balls or it can come back straight,
you know,
like you actually have a friend to play catch with.
And I've since my fucked up my shoulder,
which is feeling great now by the way.
MMM.
Since I messed it up,
I've been,
uh,
I switched to becoming a lefty and a,
I just want to get my,
my mechanics down.
I'm almost fucking there where I can get a little velocity on it.
So that's basically what I'm about.
Basically living like a goddamn eight year old and I love it.
I absolutely love it.
And uh,
you know,
we're up at this week or doing episode number eight of a f is for family four Oh
eight written by yours truly.
Um,
I've um,
eight out of 10.
So,
uh,
this season as far as like the heavy lifting,
the writing aspect of it is almost over.
Very thankful for that.
And uh,
we've always had a killer writer,
writers' room and I think this year is our strongest room.
It just keeps getting better and better.
I think that it helps that the show's been on for as long as it has.
So writers come in the room now just hitting the ground running.
They just understand the characters and all that.
So it's been,
uh,
it's definitely been great.
So with that,
I have some new dates I have to announce.
Announce.
Uh,
let's see here.
I am going to be at the cosmopolitan in Las Vegas on September 6th.
Um,
venue and ticket master Presale is Thursday matched 28th.
Uh,
the public on sale is Friday,
March 29th.
I don't know what that means.
The public can't go to ticket master.
I'll presale Jesus Christ.
There's always somebody Borden before group one isn't there?
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
I'm going to be out there.
I'm going to do a Gig and then the following day I'm going to go see Elton John
because I know this is like his last two are a lot of people wrapping it up out
there.
Lot of people wrapping it up out there on their fucking tours.
And,
um,
so I'm like,
fuck,
I gotta go see these people before the date.
They just don't talk anymore.
And then they die.
And I,
I know you're thinking,
how many times can you get suckered into that bill?
How many fucking times can somebody say it's their last fucking tore and then
they come back around again?
You know,
listen,
I forgive it if you get into some sort of tax trouble.
MMM.
You know what I mean?
Fucking taxes.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
Did I start a shitstorm on fucking reddit when I talking about the,
uh,
that taxing people,
70% money north of $10 million.
And I am passionately against that.
I don't make north of $10 million,
but I also know how taxes work.
All right?
So they'll create that and then a few years later they are going to be like,
well,
people who make eight to 10 should play this.
People who make six to eight should pay this,
and it's just going to trickle all the fucking way down.
MMM.
Yeah,
dude,
70% tech.
There's no justification for it on any level that is absolute fucking rape.
MMM.
Had people who were saying that,
uh,
that $20 trillion that is in offshore accounts is a complete separate issue,
isn't I?
Completely disagree.
That's basically like you have a house and the foundation is cracked and you're
worried that the house is going to fall into the front yard and you're sitting
there going,
we need to raise money to paint the fucking thing.
And it's like,
no.
Do we need to fix the foundation?
And you're like,
that's a separate issue.
Technically,
I guess it is a separate issue,
but it's like,
it's,
it's a more important issue.
You're going to paint something that's going to fall down on his fucking face.
All right?
If you're going to sit there and ignore that,
and you're going to ignore the fact that corporations are dictating our foreign
policy and have bankrupted this country,
this country is fucking backdrop right now.
And they're not bankrupt.
We're not bankrupt because people who make $10 million or more are not paying
70% taxes.
We're fucking bankrupt because we're spending $1 billion over $1 billion of
fucking month
fighting some shit that we could actually solve here.
We could just convert to fucking solar power if oil companies didn't own the
politicians,
you could convert to that.
Give the solar pocket the fucking sun to the oil companies so they can still
have their eyes wide shut fucking parties.
And I'm not saying solar powers cleaner,
it doesn't fucking fuck up the ocean when you throw the big fucking things in
there or whatever.
I'm not saying that,
but I'm just saying it would solve the Middle East problem
because all of that fucking terrorism is funded with oil money and nobody uses
more of it than us.
So let's just switch over.
I know it's a,
it's a,
it's a fucking,
not an easy and Deborah,
but do it like fucking Ilan mugs.
Put these little fucking glow sticks in the Goddamn road.
We'll do that.
Not for a cleaner earth,
just to get us the fuck out of there.
Cause right now they have us all walking around like zombies going,
I support the to support [inaudible] support the troops,
right?
Who does it support the fucking home team.
But they take it to the point where you create question where you're sending the
troops and for how fucking long and you can't even bring up like,
hey guys,
we're fucking bankrupt.
This isn't working.
Separate issue,
separate issue.
Let's fucking rape the guy that started dollar shave club.
That's the solution and let me guess,
let me guess.
These are the tax dollars that's are actually going to make it to public
schools.
These are the tax dollars that are going to pay for nature wide health care.
These are the tax dollars are going to fucking take over our food supply against
.
So it's not peep.
You know,
little girls aren't getting their period at 10 years old because of all the
fucking hormones in it.
Like you're going to sit there,
you want to put money on that.
This is the tax dollars.
It's going to be spent,
right.
That these fucking assholes correct piece of shit.
Politicians aren't going to steal the fuck outta here.
Do this.
People in this country make an 80 to $100 million that are paying 0% taxes,
0% taxes.
Go look up apple.
I've got an apple laptop,
right?
It's sitting right in front of me.
Go look up how they successfully avoided paying 50 billion in American taxes.
Okay.
Hey,
gay guys,
separate issue,
separate fucking issue.
All these corporations making money hand over fucking fist and as such greedy
fucking cunts,
they won't pay dollar number one on $50 billion.
Oh yeah,
no,
no.
Fuck that.
Let's go after fucking individual Americans who had the balls to go after a
fucking look at.
Let's just look at stand up comedians.
I,
I w I would if somebody told me that percentage.
I can't imagine the percentage that actually make it,
you know,
and I was that guy in my mid to late 30 sitting on a Fuckin futon.
No wife,
no kids in a fucking studio apartment
knowing that I'm in a young man's game.
Go on w where the fuck does this go,
dude,
if I don't fucking make it,
you know,
I'm going to end up on fucking cruise ships than my 50s and 60s
fighting every night and I'd throw myself over the fucking railing.
All right?
And I had the balls to stay in it,
but because I did,
you're now going to fucking punish me and demonize,
you know,
and I'm not saying I don't make that money,
but I know how this game works.
That is going to start at 10 and then it's going to fucking work its way down.
And then what's you're going to have this,
my voice is cracking.
What you're going to have is a literally a wall
between ridiculously unbelievably fucking rich people who are paying no fucking
money in taxes.
And then you're going to push the rest of everybody else backed down and have us
all fighting with one another with all of these fucking people who sent me
emails who were just saying they'd never heard me be so greedy,
like I'm greedy.
How fucking funny is that?
I'm greedy with what?
My money,
the money that I earned.
I'm fucking greedy with that.
And you who it isn't your fucking money,
uh,
telling me to give it to you and I'm the fucking greedy one.
And meanwhile,
you're going to completely ignore this other subset of people who are paying
nobody fucking taxes.
And tell me that that's a separate fucking issue.
I'm not the guy who poisoned the fucking food supply.
I'm not the one who's pouring shit into our drinking water.
I'm not the one who runs a company that makes 50 billion fucking dollars.
And I got lawyers,
a team of fucking lawyers figuring out how I can pay $0 million.
Okay?
I don't have a fucking sweatshop where people are trying to jump to that death.
And rather than pay a more fucking money,
I put nets outside of the fucking factory.
So they just land in that.
And when I can yank him out of the net and stick them back at their fucking
workstation,
I'm not the guy doing that.
But you're going to sit there and tell me that that's a separate fucking issue.
Is it a separate issue or is it just more difficult to police?
Yeah.
So you're going to go for the fucking layup.
Okay.
Unfucking believable.
It's a separate issue.
I'll sit there all day and let's see a fucking point until you say it's a
separate issue.
Paying taxes and paying your fair share is,
is fucking straight across the board.
The same issue.
And if you're going to go after people who are already paying more than 50%
taxes on their fucking income,
which is fucking criminal in my world,
that the person who does the job has to give away more.
Then they made,
they get to keep less than what they fucking made and they did the fucking job.
And you're going to sit there and tell me that.
That's fair.
The Fuck Outta here.
Yeah,
I'll never agree with that,
but I will read your fucking emails.
All of these fucking politicians are all in these fucking people's back pockets.
Don't fucking believe these Goddamn fucking people who come along and say,
I like Trump.
I'm going to,
I'm going to clean up the swell.
I'm going to drain the swamp.
He hasn't taken a fucking,
he hasn't taken a Dixie Cup worth of water out of that fucking swamp.
All right?
Cause this is what we all want to fucking do.
Ignore to really change then you would have to have an all out fucking
revolution and there would have to be bloodshed and the only people that really
have the ability to do it would be those lunatics and blackwater.
They would be the only guys who be able to do it at.
All you have to do is cross your fingers and pray that they're decent fucking
human beings because they actually have the weaponry to pull it off.
Other than that,
all you're going to do is fucking go after innocent fucking people,
which is what you guys are.
Uh,
some of you are fucking
advocating while you ignore the fucking 9,000 pound gorilla in the room who's
paying $0 million in taxes.
All right.
I'm done until I read it more later on.
Did you guys watch any of the,
um,
I picked someone who makes 50 grand a year,
should be paying 59% taxes.
MMM.
[inaudible]
all right.
Did you guys watch it?
Do you guys watch the Duke for Central Florida game?
Oh my God.
What a fucking heartbreak of that was.
I didn't know what to do cause I love Duke,
but I also root for an underdog.
And uh,
it was June the end of that game.
It was like the basketball gods just chose fucking doke.
You know that alley?
I don't know if it looked like it was mistimed.
I don't know what.
And then the fucking Duke misses it and then gets the fucking rebound and then
the shot in the end and the tip and just didn't,
it just didn't want to fucking go in.
Um,
you know,
I'll tell you right now,
if you're a fucking NBA fan,
you're missing out.
You're missing out in what's left of college basketball because there's so many
one and done.
It's just a pleasure to watch
that level of talent and they're actually listening to their coach because
that's just what's missing in the fucking NBA.
Yeah.
This fucking shit where it's just like,
these guys are the,
they make so much fucking money that,
that they,
they feel like they don't have to listen to their coach.
I just don't,
and I'm not saying all of them,
but just,
it just blows my fucking mind.
It's like you're a platoon and that's the general and he's coming in with the
fight plan and you're like,
ah Nah,
Nah,
we're just going to Improv this.
We're just going to go,
we're all going to go in there and just start open fire and you know,
in the same general fucking direction.
I just feel like when you do that,
that's when a team that on paper isn't as good as you can come in and you're
open yourself up to getting beat.
Um,
that's what it is,
man.
That is,
that is,
that is the,
how the NBA game is played now.
What is the individual fucking game?
It's the an one influence on the game,
which I'm not on a percent against that level of fucking creativity in one on
one and all that type of shit.
But like,
you know when you have like a coach just sitting there with his fucking thumbs
up his ass cause he can only talk to the lower fucking 70% of the team.
You know what I mean?
It's almost like those superstars are like apple,
right.
Don't want to pay their taxes.
They don't want or they think they think they're above being coached.
Um,
anyways,
everything's going to go back to that.
I've been paying attention to the premier league.
Liverpool is still two points ahead but I looked up to schedule this time cause
I thought that they were in the lead.
It's just they've played more games.
They have nine games left and Man City has 11 games left.
And as far as I can tell,
none of them really have that much challenging games left other than man city
plays.
Man United.
That could be the,
the fly in the ointment game there.
So I'll try to pay attention.
I'll,
I'll watch that game cause I figured that's going to be a big one.
Um,
and then I'm going to be watching the Bruins verse Tampa Bay Lightening Tonight.
That's going to be my,
uh,
that's going to be my little fucking a
my little evening tonight.
And,
uh,
I mentioned,
last week I went,
I went to the premiere,
that Motley Crue movie the dirt,
definitely check it out just to fucking,
I,
I really loved the movie.
Uh,
didn't pull any punches and uh,
I actually saw some woman in the La Times was,
was given one of the band members shit going like,
how could you put a movie out post me too.
How could you put a movie out like this?
And the dude was like,
well,
I mean it happened.
You want us to rewrite history?
It was like the perfect fucking answer.
And if you watch it,
what's so fucked up is it's,
it's all consensual sex.
It's just a bunch of people over indulging.
So have we got in literally to this point that,
that a bunch of guys playing in a band who have a bunch of groupies who want to
fuck the shit out of them.
So they do is like a bad fuck.
Is,
is like somehow like that there was something wrong there.
I mean,
you could say there was something wrong as far as like a,
what everybody was doing there.
If you want to get into some sort of religious debate about morals leaving,
if you want to get out of religion and just talk about the emptiness of living a
life like that,
how it's exciting in the beginning,
but then afterwards is a profound loneliness to living a life like that for both
people,
the Groupie and the fucking rock star.
I can have that fucking conversation with you,
but I don't understand how that fucking,
you know,
I thought me too was you took your dick out at working just on a plan,
right?
I was in that world,
Wasn't played some songs and chicks in the crowd is showing that titties to you
and then afterwards you bang them.
Yeah.
I,
I didn't think that that,
that fell under that fucking umbrella
does meet to basically you also get to the point of like,
you know,
the,
that that men can't go out and enjoy themselves if they're out there.
And then if you play in a band,
it's going to its rated pussy.
You know,
that's going to happen.
There's actually people that got into bands
just for the chicks and all of a sudden they're fucking,
they're bad.
Somehow fucking made it.
And this standing up there without that passion is pussy.
Look at Gene Simmons.
I've never heard that guy talk passionately about music.
He just talks passionately about women.
Okay.
Any so obsessed with it.
He literally says Dumb Shit.
Like anybody who says they got into a bed for the music is a fucking liar.
They got in it for the pussy.
I made it.
That's how that far down the fucking road that guy is.
If everybody doesn't share my opinion,
yeah,
then then,
uh,
they're fucking lying.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah,
it was,
it was 30,
40 fucking years ago.
And uh,
you know,
I dunno.
Motley Crue did what a lot of bands did and they made a fucking movie about it.
And even then,
it's sorta like,
they kind of glossed over a lot of it.
So I don't,
I don't understand what the fucking problem is.
There's always somebody now that's got some sort of problems.
Don't you think that that movie about seagulls,
Josie,
does it misses the mark about the main issue?
The main issue being the issue that am I'm concerned with.
Okay.
By the way,
my favorite thing right now on the Internet is crystally is,
uh,
that thing.
He did that thing,
he's trying to start jokingly or not called the unfollowing
follow Chris Delea on Instagram and scroll through.
I'm sure he's made a couple of videos since his last one.
He did this fucking thing on,
I was talking about,
I think I would just talked about this,
but I just want to promote it again because I think it's like all those
Instagram models,
you know,
it goes,
uh,
hey,
he goes,
make no mistake if you're on Instagram and you're taking pictures of your booty
and your Teddy's,
yeah.
Okay.
And he literally breaks it down to all of this shit that I didn't even know
existed,
I guess.
You know,
hot chicks biting into a giant sandwich,
like looking up in the air,
trying to be,
try to be cute or something like that.
And it's like,
uh,
I don't know.
He's just saying to unfollow them,
which is fucking funny to me
because I'm not in that world at all.
But I was talking to younger comics about this and I,
you know,
they run into these people I guess,
and they were saying like,
yeah,
they actually come up to you and have like an attitude.
Like they're doing something now they are doing something.
They are going to the gym.
They are keeping themselves in shape and God bless him in an entrepreneurial
way.
I respect the fact that they're building a brand here.
MMM.
Yeah.
But
I don't,
uh,
I don't co sign on then walking around acting like an egotistical maniac.
If that's what the fuck that dude,
I don't fucking know.
There's so much shit on it.
That's fucking hilarious.
I saw somebody made,
made a post where they would talk when it was women's Day and of course they
were like,
you know,
fuck that.
It should be women's Day,
everyday of the year.
Which is hilarious because it's just like,
and when would it be guys day then?
Does that seem fair to you?
And the person like took like a fucking picture and it's like a sexy picture.
Like they couldn't just make their,
their statement.
They also had to show off their fucking,
you know,
they have flat stomach and their fucking ass and stuff.
It's just like,
it's like what,
what are you,
what are we doing here?
It's like if that exact picture,
if a guy used it to sell like,
uh,
like you know,
some Coca Cola,
it'd be like objectifying women.
It's Yo Yo Dee what needs to change?
But then,
you know,
I dunno,
but then you can do it if it's you doing it to yourself selling woman's Day.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't get out of the fucking math works,
but you know something I was never good at math.
All I can tell you this is,
I don't think Lebron James should have to give away 70% of his money over $10
million.
I don't,
I think he's already fucking play in well over 50 Tom Brady,
all of these fucking people and I think you know something.
I think you paying your fair share at that point.
How much more fucking money do you want to take from these fucking people while
ignoring people who are paying no money in taxes?
Why?
Ignoring companies that are leading us off into war that has no end,
that bankrupts the country.
That's a separate issue.
Oh Jesus.
All right,
let me read some advertising here.
Hey,
my book ea,
I look funky door and I write,
um,
brackets.
First round upsets.
The final four march madness is here,
right there on your television screen.
It's time to bet with the best at my bookie.
Hey,
would you rather sit at your office desk or call out sick and binge on NCAA
tournament games and junk food like,
that's okay.
All right,
let's see.
Would you,
would you rather I am the worst?
Would you rather sit at your office desk or call out sick and binge on NCA
tournament games and junk food?
Like that's even a choice.
I love how these guys,
they're not even trying to hide how to generate,
they are gamble on sports.
It don't go to work.
Don't even have an apple eat some freedoms anyways.
Sometimes it feels good to be bad.
It's the balance of life,
especially when it's with someone you trust.
And if you're looking for a place to get in on the action,
you can trust my bookie.
They'd been in business for years and they're growing like wow.
Fat.
The best part is they pay out fast.
So when you call that 12 over five upset this year,
make sure to celebrate.
You'll be pocketing cold,
hard cash,
uh,
core talking points.
March madness is the most exciting action packed sporting event of the year.
Even grandmothers fill out brackets.
Place your bets with Mike bookie.
Now before you miss out my back,
my book,
you will match your deposit with a 50% bonus.
Use Promo code bird to activate the offer.
Visit my bookie.
Dot.
Agee today you play,
you win.
You get paid only at my bookie.
Dot.
A g.
All right.
Oh look who's here.
Oh,
oh,
zip.
But up hiring used to be hard.
Oh my God,
it's so difficult.
You know,
writing where?
Hiring on a sign,
sticking it in a window,
hoping that dream person walked by and they need a job.
It ain't like that anymore.
All right.
With Ziprecruiter,
ZipRecruiter's sends you wait,
sends your job to over 100 of the web's leading job boards,
but they don't stop there with their powerful matching technologies.
Zip
[inaudible].
Yeah,
good scans,
thousands of job resumes to find out people with the right experience and invite
them to apply to your job.
As applications come in,
zip recruiter analyzes each one and spotlights the top candidates so you never
miss a great match.
Zip [inaudible],
um,
is so effective that 80% of employees who post on Zip,
okay.
Get a quality candidate through the site within the first day.
And right now my listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free at the exclusive
website address,
ziprecruiter.com/burr that zip
recruiter.com/bar one more time.
Zip Good.
Hey,
gretta.com/burns
zip,
the smartest way to hire.
Oh Geez.
We've got a lot today.
What do we got here?
What do we,
what do we have here?
Uh,
you know what,
I got one,
two,
three left,
so I'm going to break them up.
I'll read the third one here.
We'll get over the hump.
This is Wednesday here.
Simply safe.
Hi fellas.
Here's something interesting.
Studies show that security systems deter burglars
its effect,
but there's still a burglary every eight seconds in America.
Um,
how well think about it.
Think about it.
Do Burglars Give Up?
Just because some housewife houses have security systems?
Of course not.
They just find a house that isn't protected.
That's why securing your home is truly necessary.
So wait a minute.
So everybody ends up getting a security system that these guys are going to have
to up their game like a virus because of,
uh,
you know,
if you don't kill the virus,
you just keep using the medicine.
They get immune to it.
We have to kill the virus.
Yeah.
So simply safe,
what I would be doing if I was them,
I would eventually,
I would come with up with a security system that known only deters the intruder.
It also kills them.
All right.
But that's a different read.
Simply save sensors will protect every point of access of two year home doors,
windows,
garage,
you name it.
Yeah.
If a burglar even tries to break in and ear shattering side,
remember those old cy five things where they would shoot like as sound rape at
somebody.
They would just grab both their resume and be like,
yeah,
drop to their knees.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
I just pictured the burglar dressed like Captain Kirk.
A best of all,
simply say's 24 you wouldn't want him and his your fucking house.
He tried to bang your wife.
Burst of all simply saves 24 seven monitoring is just 14,909 a month and they'll
never lock you in a longterm contract.
More than 3 million people already know.
It feels good to feel less with simply safe.
So go with the only home security system you can trust.
Simply safe by going to simply say bird.com B u r R,
go today and get free shipping and a 60 day money back guarantee.
That's simply safe.
bird.com for home security.
S I m P.
L I s?
A.
F.
E.
Yeah.
bird.com.
All right,
let's plow ahead.
Alright.
Cubans role too tight.
Hey Billy suction face.
Uh,
if you're Cubans turn your face purple when you smoke them then they are
probably counterfeit.
I know people tell me that but you know something.
I have to be honest with you.
I get a lot of Dominicans,
I get a lot of Nicaraguans and I run into this same problem.
Not the same problem with the Cubans.
So if somebody making fake Nicaraguans and Dominican's anyways,
the demand for Cuban cigars far,
far outweighs the availability.
Um,
is another thing too sir.
I fucking,
I've smoked him in different countries and I've had run into the same problem.
Maybe you're saying the worldwide demand,
which you're probably right so they are often faked in nearly indistinguishable
from the real deal.
Even for the train I,
it's only when you start smoking them that it's noticeable.
Rolling a good cigar is a true art which is not mastered by counterfeiters
looking for a quick buck.
The demand for Dominican's for example,
is a lot lower and they are not,
and they are not considered extremely rare or valuable.
They are rarely counterfeit greetings from get Belgium and as per go fuck
yourself while he is in Belgium.
So yeah.
Yeah.
I gotta be honest with you,
I'm kind of getting away from the Cubans because they're,
they're really expensive.
And um,
I remember one time when I was in Australia,
I must've got the real deal because I,
I bought these Cohibas and when I came back they were,
they were,
they were incredible.
Like they were a cigar that as you will lighting it,
like the first couple of puffs you went,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's believing what you do.
Your whole body fucking relaxes.
And it's an amazing,
having said that,
I would like to quit those.
That might be the next thing that I want to do.
And I am,
um,
I am,
I would like to just replace all my vices with something a little more healthy
and then eventually come back to a vice that isn't a bad vice.
What's your vice,
you know,
I guess I think I read too much in bad lighting.
I have to stop.
I know I'm so bad.
I need to go to meetings.
Like I'd love to be that fucking person,
you know?
Um,
so eventually I think I'm gonna like get down to maybe like three,
four cigars a year.
The Rose Bowl,
the big college game,
my birthday,
and then something around Christmas and,
and um,
yeah,
just sort of leave it at that because I am really getting into living like a
fucking nerd.
MMM.
You know,
it's underrated or overrated.
Underrated.
I'll tell you underrated reading a great book at night to make you sleepy rather
than staring at a screen.
And A,
I've kind of realized that one of my vices is the amount of time that I spend on
my phone.
And,
um,
I want to get used to like not being,
uh,
you know,
I,
I'd like,
I'll be in the car and I just find myself going over and picking it up like,
like a fucking child with,
with its little favorite teddy bear.
And I'm fucking sitting there looking at the God damn screen and it's like I'm
driving,
scrolling,
trying to find a song.
MMM,
okay.
So I think what I'm going to just,
I try to put it in airplane mode,
but then most of my songs around the fucking cloud and then I lose all my
goddamn music.
So now what I'm gonna do is I'm going to have a playlist,
download those,
you know,
10 songs or whatever,
and then put it on airplane mode and then literally take the thing and fucking
throw it in the back seat.
MMM.
I would like to do that.
And um,
but I'll tell you,
man,
underrated fucking reading.
I'm back into it.
And,
uh,
and I told you I had this woman tell me that I,
um,
I wasn't going to be able to learn French.
So back to the flash cards and stuff.
And,
uh,
I got a couple of friends of mine that can speak French.
So we only text each other strictly in French.
And I'm not,
I'm really starting to learn this shit.
I can't speak it well,
but I can read it really well now,
or at least to another level.
And it's,
uh,
I mean,
I could,
I could fucking be doing that rather than slowly killing myself and killing
brain cells and shit.
And,
um,
I dunno man.
I think,
uh,
you know,
like I had that cookout yesterday and there was a bunch of people over and shit
and I was stoned,
fucking sober.
So then,
you know,
jumbo walking around and then I run into my kid,
hey,
are you doing,
I'm not like buzzed.
They,
there's a low point in your fucking life.
Yeah.
You know,
having a little buzz going and then you see it fucking kid.
It's just like,
what am I doing?
What if something happens right now?
And I need to react and I'm a little buzzed right now.
I just can't fucking do it anymore.
But the guilt of it,
I can't handle it.
So,
um,
anyways,
I agree with you,
sir.
I like the,
uh,
the Casa Magnus,
the,
uh,
I,
I swear to God,
I think they're called collegal.
He us like that fucking half a porno movie.
Um,
I like the Aurora emeralds and um,
he has a couple of my father's cigars that I really like,
but um,
I don't know.
I'm going to be basically trying to phase those fuckers out.
All right.
Card Games and board games.
Um,
hey bill catching up on the podcast.
I heard you had fun playing cards.
Yeah,
I loved it.
Played with my mom.
It was awesome.
Uh,
you should check out the word.
Um,
the world of card games and board games.
There's a regular popular game called five crowns.
That's a rummy style game.
That is fun.
Also,
board games have come a long way.
I feel like you may have been a risk guy.
I was,
I loved that game.
Taking over the world.
Uh,
though I don't recall you saying,
Oh,
I love that fucking game.
Uh,
there are great strategy games out there that are fun to play with.
Friends and cigars.
Uh,
people love settlers of Catan or Katon.
Again,
that is probably sold thriller like numbers in the tabletop game world.
I'm going to check that out.
Hey,
you know what?
I missed?
I lost.
Um,
let me see if I,
that meditation fucking music.
I lost.
Uh,
you fucking asshole bill.
I was really looking forward to that shit.
God Damn.
I'll be able to find it.
Yeah,
I guess it's just that music that goes on for like fucking three hours or I can
just go back and listen to my old pod.
She,
you know,
is,
um,
is amazing here.
I don't,
I don't even know how to fight.
Sorry.
I just unplugged something.
I don't even know how to fucking listen to my own podcast.
How pathetic is that?
Um,
okay.
All right.
I'll definitely be checking these things out.
He says there's a game called secret
that's pretty involved.
I'm not sure you'd have time in your schedule,
but it's worth looking at.
Seek.
There's a game called secret Hitler
object.
Find the person in the game who's had,
who's starting the final solution again.
Um,
even the classics are fun to revisit.
Monopoly life,
et cetera.
Yeah,
I love that stuff.
And my kid gets a little bit bigger.
I want to start playing those games.
Have a game night.
We already have the night where we go out.
This will kill my standup career game that I can't,
I can't do that Gig.
I have game night.
I have to go out for 'em.
I have to go out,
take my family out for dinner.
Hey,
by the way,
anybody who lives in La and you know some really good mom and pop places,
it doesn't have to be healthy or anything.
What in the fuck is that?
Oh,
it's a cat.
Jesus Christ.
I thought it was a raccoon.
I just saw a fucking cat
just came up on the fucking window through the blinds.
Who's like looking in like it was going to do something?
Yeah,
cancer.
Creepy man.
They just,
they just are mad.
They just always,
they,
they think too much.
You look at a dog,
it's at this not fucking thinking about anything.
Catch just had that fucking that they're plotting,
you know,
very female energy.
Yeah.
If you just sit next to your girlfriend and you just feel,
I'm thinking,
you're like,
oh fuck.
Here we go.
What's wrong now?
What the fuck is wrong now?
All right,
girlfriend forcing me to go vegan.
Speaking of which,
I bet that guy filtered thinking.
Uh,
first of all,
before we even get into this,
uh,
your girl [inaudible] cannot force you to do anything.
You need to fucking eat a steak in front of her and say,
listen,
you either love me or you dump.
I already know the solution to this
all.
[inaudible]
hey,
Billy,
longtime listener and first time I've written in as I desperately need some
advice.
My girl and I have been together for about eight months.
She's awesome.
And I get laid about three times a week.
All right.
Um,
weird sentence.
Uh,
things have gradually gotten more serious and we now spend most evenings
together eating dinner even though we don't stay over with each other every
night.
Well,
that's good.
That's healthy that you still have a little bitty independence.
We mostly eat dinner at her place,
so she does the grocery shopping and she's also Vegan,
which isn't bad dude.
She's,
you know,
provided she's buying,
I guess organic.
How do you even tell if it's organic?
Because I've heard from a lot of people,
and this might come from the meat industry,
I've no idea,
but I've heard from a lot of people that,
you know,
the amount of pesticides,
the spraying,
I'm sometimes actually eating some iceberg lettuce might be more for you than
eating a fucking pig.
Um,
who knows.
Also she's a Vegan.
She recently decided that she was not going to buy meat for me.
So it's easy to cook.
Plus it's better for the environment and health.
Basically.
All the fucking arguments vegans use against us.
Carnivores.
Yeah.
All the cows farting and up into the atmosphere.
I do love me,
but also love this girl and would honestly go Vegan for,
should I just be done with it and cut,
cut it meat.
Oh,
see I knew you meant to say cut out meat or am I setting setting the tone for
the whole relationship to get treated like a little bitch.
Appreciate your advice.
All right.
I like that you're asking these questions,
sir.
So you're still in a healthy place mentally.
Ah,
that's what I would say to her.
Just be like,
listen.
MMM.
I'm willing to do this for us,
but I'm also,
I would be lying to you if I wasn't nervous that I was setting a tone that,
you know,
if say you don't like March madness that I'm Grad,
I'm eventually going to stop watching it.
So you got to do it in the front of your way than that.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I don't think going Vegan if the person knows what the fuck they're doing.
Cause there's a lot of fat vegetarians out there,
um,
who are eating chips and has made from potatoes.
Um,
but the,
you know,
they're not necessarily healthy.
You know,
when the carbon it up.
Um,
I know there's a lot of fake meat and shit out there now.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of ways to go.
MMM.
I am not nearly read enough on this subject to give you any sort of advice as to
which way to go.
But I think your concern is correct.
MMM.
I would just go slow.
I would just say,
all right,
look,
if you just want to cook Vegan here and then I would just,
which isn't bad,
it's not bad to take a break from me that I wouldn't think.
Um,
I dunno,
I,
but I also know that it to really do
do the Vegan thing correctly.
I actually,
you know something to be a meat eater and,
and,
and just eat them.
Just really eat well is you borderline need a fucking degree in something.
First of all,
you got to be half a fucking private eye to try and figure out where the organic
shit is because everything now is free range.
Everything is fucking Oregon.
The amount of chickens that they say are fucking free range,
but there's still those fucking Arnold Schwartzenegger roided up fucking
chickens.
Cause I remember when I watched that,
that documentary,
um,
I forgot what the fuck it was called.
A not,
you are what you eat something about food.
And I saw,
I was like,
man,
fuck this.
I got to go find an organic chicken dude.
I mean,
I,
I had to go to a farmer's market and then I had to sift through all the bullshit
there and get people to honestly tell me this guy finally,
almost like he had the Cuban,
the actual real Cubans in the back.
And when he held up,
when he showed me a what a real chicken looks like,
it looks,
I was like,
is that what,
is that a fucking pigeon?
It's like,
no,
that's,
that's what they're supposed to look like.
Yeah.
It looked like a play a football player in the 1930s versus one in the fucking
eighties and nineties when they were fucking all roid it up.
Not like they're not doing right now.
Um,
Oh,
speaking of which,
uh,
football players,
congratulations to rob Gronkowski going out as a champion.
Thank you so much for all your fucking everything it did over the years playing
for the Patriots.
And I actually think it's a great move.
Um,
especially when you see,
you know,
the results of playing the game and all that.
I think he's leaving at a perfect time.
He's got his money.
MMM.
He was really taken a lot of hits basically below the waist,
which was the only way to get them down.
And they would just chop and his fucking legs down.
And he was probably sick of going into surgeries and being hurt and all of that.
And just the fact that the last game he played,
he made the biggest fucking play,
that big catch that got us to touch down.
That uh,
put us over the top and one s are six super bowl.
Um,
yeah.
Hall of fame,
New England Patriot without a doubt.
I don't know.
You know,
I don't collect football cards anymore,
so I don't know what his,
uh,
his numbers are.
But I,
I,
I got a good feeling about the actual pro football hall of fame in Canton.
So,
and I also did a roast with them one time and he was such a fucking cool guy.
And,
uh,
there's a lot of people out there that think he says big dumb guy and he isn't.
I remember I was talking to him about,
MMM,
we've talking about going to concerts and he was saying how much he fucking
hated.
How people was sitting there videoing their experience rather than having the
experience he's going like,
it's like you're there,
enjoy the experience and all I remember thinking in that going,
I wish people could hear this fucking conversation so that,
you know,
cause they always just think,
they always think that about big fucking people that,
that they're fucking dumb.
He was not,
he was not any,
did great on the roast.
Uh,
Betty was funny,
you know.
Anyways,
so plowing ahead here.
I would,
um,
you know,
I would use this thing as an opportunity to basically yet set some boundaries in
your relationship in a funny way and just be like,
all right,
you know what,
I'll be Vegan when I'm at your house and if,
um,
you know,
she's pushing you to become Vegan and your house just be like,
I,
I really enjoy a steak.
I really do.
And,
um,
I'm going to keep eating it
and if you're going to break up with me over a pork chop than,
uh,
they're probably really wasn't love here in the first place.
Um,
meanwhile,
you know,
yeah.
Read up on fucking nutrition.
I mean I'm,
I'm giving you advice that I should be taken.
I should read up on it too because I've been really well over the last year and
now that I've,
uh,
I should say since July and I'm,
I had somebody put together a died for me and I pretty much loosely use that
with some of my older bad habits.
I'm not going to lie to you and um,
and just cutting out the booze,
it's been really easy to sort of maintain.
Okay.
Um,
uh,
a decent body weight is probably the smartest thing that you could fucking do.
Learn how to defend yourself and learn how to eat right.
You know,
figure out why you fucked up so you don't take it out on somebody else and go
out and go find a great person and then work on the relationship like this
person's doing rather than bailing.
Cause I actually have a theory about divorce where I think a lot of them,
they could have fixed it if they just were working on it along the way.
And then you just start thinking like,
oh,
this person's a fucking asshole.
And then he just had this fantasy that you're going to
meets it.
You just basically chasing that feeling you had when you both met each other in
the beginning and you just never going to be brand new.
You just have to accept that.
But you can get back to different levels of emotional heights if you actually
work on it.
Like the dumbest thing ever.
Just doing shit.
Like,
you know what family dinner night and everybody puts away their phones or
whatever and it's just you.
Or if you're single or whatever,
you may not married,
you can go out to a movie.
Okay.
And uh,
I'm telling you,
turn it off your phone is a fucking huge thing,
um,
that I've discovered,
especially if you get fucking massive add like me.
Okay.
Um,
where are we here?
Big Sugar.
Yeah.
All right.
I can't tell if this is a place to go skiing or this is more stuff about food.
Hey,
Billy bald balls.
Last week or so you went off on one email proposing a massive tax on the rich.
No,
I didn't.
I did not.
I went off on a massive tax on honest Americans.
Okay.
This is not a tax on the rich.
This is a tax on people who are not smart enough or corrupt enough to have their
money in offshore accounts.
That's what I went off on.
Okay.
He said then I learned about how tax dollars are feeding billions to sugar
industry.
The U s government has subsidized the domestic sugar industry so much that
domestic sugar prices are up to 50% more than their international counterparts.
Separate issue.
Separate issue
the government does is by establishing quotas that limit imports.
So now more domestic production means that there is more farmland to take up by
sugar.
Yeah.
Which is people are starting to say is a carcinogen.
Um,
there's another thing too,
when you cut sugar out of your diet,
like I've been having this fucking almond butter.
I know.
Big Hollywood fucking phony.
You have to apologize for trying to eat right.
Right.
Uh,
it's like when I drove a Prius,
savage dude,
but he fucking,
you know,
sandals homophobic shit to me cause I was cause you're just reminding people
that hey man,
the way we're doing this shit is steering us into the fucking sun here.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
and my wife had bought some peanut butter for my daughter and it was just the
regular kind and I,
you know,
we ran out of almond butter and I put some on some toast and I bit into it and I
have fortunately such little amount of sugar,
my diet.
Then I bit into it like I literally am like my fucking my mouth puckered like
Jesus Christ.
I had no idea how much sugar is in fucking peanut butter.
It's insane.
So anyways,
he goes,
if you are wondering why kids are getting beards at 10,
then this might be why these companies don't want to pay for real sugar.
So they just make another sweet poison and call it sugar free lead volume.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The environmental impacts are also dire with sugar beets causing worsening soil
quality and water pollution that is much worse than other crops.
The worst part of all is,
is the insane amount of money these bastards get like one Florida farm families
getting 150 to 250 million that comes out of the taxpayer's pocket.
Separate issue.
Also,
the increased sugar prices may companies in food processing,
you have to lay off 10,000 to 20,000 employees a year while sugar growers can
usually make up to $750,000 a year,
sorry,
750 million a year.
No,
70 to 50,000 a year.
That doesn't make any sense that you put the wrong number there.
Um,
uh,
the American sugar alliance is one of the most funded lobbying groups with a
handful of companies bringing in the mass amounts of the 4 billion in subsidies
the tax payers give.
I hope you found this important and interesting and has always go fuck yourself.
Yeah.
Handful of look at that is one of the most funded lobbying groups.
Yep.
And what do you think all that money goes?
Yeah.
Do you think it just goes to the lobbying or do you think it goes into
politicians pet projects?
It's fucking ridiculous how corrupt that is.
And you're going to go after the people who create an APP or people who start
movement watches.
These are these,
these people are the fucking,
yeah,
they had the fucking problem.
You can ignore all the corruptions.
So here's a guy here who's basically going to fucking tear me a new asshole.
Alright?
And I love the title.
Why I stopped listening.
And this is the classic baby that exists now.
You know,
you,
you know you,
you don't,
you,
you have a difference of opinion.
So you're going to stop listening.
You fucking child
is,
if my words somehow affected your life,
like I said,
that and then what the IRS
is actually going to be going after these fucking people did not.
All right.
Why?
I stopped listening,
Bill,
I've stopped listening to your pod.
What are you fucking eight years old?
I felt that I should tell you why.
[inaudible] much like a restaurant who loses a loyal customer,
wants to know why,
what went wrong?
You,
you know,
you love always putting those words in my mouth.
Like I give a fuck that an absolute child isn't going to listen to my fucking
podcast.
Uh,
so no hard feelings,
but here it is.
You should like flip your hair right now.
Like d Schneider.
Is that his name?
The guy from twisted sister,
when he made that point,
you know when he was in front of Congress about the PMRC man.
Um,
I've never heard a more selfish mouth breathing uninformed money grubbing cont
speak in my entire life.
This is what I love.
I don't even know.
I don't make $10 million a year.
So I was actually defending people whose tax money would actually go,
I guess to help me.
And somehow I'm money grubbing because this person's so up the ass of their own
fucking point.
They can't even listen to what it is that I'm saying.
He goes,
sometimes you say something halfway smart,
but it is surrounded.
He says my so much bullshit.
He's calling me dumb.
He didn't even hit spellcheck by so much bullshit.
It makes me feel you stumbled into saying it by accident.
Yes sir.
Because no one could ever be as smart as you like how a monkey banging on a
typewriter might somehow type out Shakespeare.
I don't think a monkey banging out a typewriter.
It might somehow type out Shakespeare.
Think what you meant meant to say is that he might accidentally spell a word
correctly,
like might accidentally spelled the or APP.
I don't think you meant Shakespeare.
All right.
You know what I'm finding,
I think you wrote this in a very high emotional state here.
So I'll cut you some slack.
And uh,
I've always said I'm a moron.
Okay.
And even now that I'm reading,
I'm reading like the fucking Beastie boy autobiography.
I'm reading the fucking,
which actually is,
I'm finding out,
uh,
is,
is a history book,
um,
on a certain John Rowe of music that I believe the kids call hip hop.
Um,
all right.
The biggest problem is you cannot see beyond your own experience making $10
million a year is not my experience.
I've never made $10 million in a year.
Okay.
And this is most evident in your recent diatribe about the 70% tax rate.
I Dunno.
I like to think I,
I get,
you know,
I don't always,
but I like to think,
you know,
I try,
I try to listen.
Listen to both sides I guess.
I guess I,
I guess I don't,
in case your memory is blinded your own rage.
Uh,
what about your rage?
Let me go over some dumb ass things that you said on Monday,
March 18th.
First of all,
sir,
you calling me a mouth breather and you're saying that I have rage and you're
literally misspelling words and you're so angry at me right now that you can't
present your opinion without calling me names anyways.
You call people making 10 million plus a year.
Regular guys who are deserving of empathy.
Sure.
Some are your woe is me.
Lament of these poor,
poor millionaires made my blood boil.
Exactly,
exactly.
Ig.
Look how you just phrase that.
Look at these poor,
poor millionaires.
You're judging them and who they are because of how much money they make.
And you're going to turn it into a Disney movie where anybody who make some
money is fucking evil.
Makes my bud blood boil.
Fuck you.
This guy literally just said blinded by rage.
You implied that money tax from millionaires goes directly back to lazy cons
making less.
I don't remember saying that.
Maybe I did.
All right.
You said it isn't fair that people being honest with their income have to pay
this rate.
Uh,
while rich people hide their incomes overseas.
You also said that tax money is being wasted,
wasted.
And then it just says corrupt bullshit.
I agree with both of these things.
These are separate problems that also need to be fixed.
You're often being,
you're often being dumb bullshit like this
up.
What is,
if the government can't do two things at once.
Okay.
I think with your fucking half written email,
calling me a moron,
ser,
they're not going after these people.
Yeah,
they're not
okay.
It's been deemed too difficult.
Okay.
Because what they do is be,
I already explained this shit,
is how was it explained to me in layman's term?
You have a fucking company,
okay?
You have a bunny,
a pile of fucking money.
So you crew.
So you fucking either incorporate,
yeah,
in a a a different country or you,
you create a,
a fake,
phony fucking company in that country,
which bills you're legit company a ridiculous amount of fucking money.
So then you're then able to show that your company somehow lost money.
So now you don't have to pay any taxes,
but now your money is in this fake company.
So how do you get it right?
You'd be having it in this foreign fucking island,
right?
Which is a different country.
You pay some people off there,
so you let the money go.
Then you start another company in a different island,
and then they build that company and you just keep going hopscotch and through
the fucking Caribbean or wherever the fuck this shit goes down.
All right?
And then the last company goes back to you and gives you like 50 million,
$100 million in the form of alone,
which is untakeable,
and then you're allegedly going to pay it back,
which you don't.
And when you don't,
that phony fucking company forgives the loan.
That's the base that in layman's terms,
that's the way it was explained to me.
And the problem is,
is that with each one of those islands that it goes through,
it's,
it's a whole new fucking,
it's a different country,
a different government,
and you have to go through a mountain of red tape.
So they have seven,
10 14 of these fucking companies all ping pong and all through the fucking
islands.
And it just be,
it just,
it's too difficult.
It's too difficult.
And then what you have is honest fucking people who took a fucking chance.
Okay.
And risk basically sleeping alone on a Fuckin futon with no wife,
no fucking family maxed out there.
Fucking credit cards.
And most of those people lose.
And then you're going to come in to take,
there's no way you can present an argument or 70000070% paying taxes on one
fucking dollar,
70% you cannot set that fucking precedent by the government,
okay?
Considering they are complete corrupt pieces of shit.
A standup comedian is not a corrupt piece of shit,
okay?
He's not looking at the other way with all that shit that person just said about
sugar.
These are not separate issues.
What you have as a broken fucking system,
which is now going to take,
put duct tape on the fucking problem and go after innocent fucking people and
for you to call me a moron because you just sit there and you,
oh,
these poor,
poor millionaires.
If somebody is fucking honest,
they shouldn't have to fucking pay for it.
Look at the Clintons.
Look at the bushes.
Look at the Obamas.
Look at them.
Look how fucking corrupt they are.
The most he ever made was foreign and fucking 500 fucking grand being president
of the United States and they're all worth millions and millions and millions of
does go look,
go.
Look at who they fucking give this speech to go look at it.
Who Obama's first two fucking speeches where to like two of the biggest fucking
banks that were behind the 2008 scandal
and they're going up vacuuming up all that fucking money.
It's fucking Michelle Obama has the fucking balls to put out an inspirational
book on how to be a better fucking person.
It makes your dreams come true is she has all that corporate money fucking
fallen out from between her fucking titties.
Get the fuck Outta here.
What I want
to,
I want you to,
if you're still listening,
what you,
I know you are.
What?
Poor poor millionaires.
Well why do you,
why are you judging somebody?
Cause they fucking had the balls to put their entire future on the fucking three
zillion to one dog with the limp at the back of the fucking race.
And the thing came in.
So now they have to give away 70% of their money north of $10 million.
Listen,
if you're saying that that's what the number is in,
everybody's going to pay 70% north,
you know,
north of $10 million,
which once again,
I'm not making,
so I'm literally arguing for fucking people that I'm not okay.
But I plan on making more than that and I'm in a country that allows me to do
it.
Thank Christ.
All right?
And I hope that you fucking do it someday.
And it's not my fucking fault that you don't have the fucking balls or an idea
or the charisma or whatever the fuck you need to get to that level.
I haven't had it yet,
but I'm not going to,
just because I haven't,
I'm not gonna fucking punish these other fucking people.
And here's the thing.
If every mother fucker in this country,
yeah,
okay,
making north of $10 million had to fucking pay that.
Okay,
then you are going somewhere.
But here's the fucking thing though.
Here's the thing though.
Where is that money going to go?
Are you going to fix where the fuck it's going to go?
Because are you going to somehow fix our fucking foreign policy?
So we don't get broke flight in 3,500 jerk offs on a fucking jungle gym.
You're going to ignore all of those fucking problems and just take a select few
group of fucking Americans who did nothing wrong,
made it in a sports,
created a watch company,
created a shaving company,
fucking created some something in their standup act that fucking made enough
Americans want to go to this show that they're making a,
you're going to punish them.
You're going to co sign on.
They have to give away 70% of that fucking money.
I just can't get behind that.
I mean,
all of these politician blow in these fucking people who aren't paying fucking
taxes
and then they're going to come out the other side and then go give speeches to
people who don't pay fucking taxes and companies that don't pay fucking taxes
and take that money and stick it in their fucking pocket and go buy themselves a
big mansion on fucking Martha's vineyard.
That's all fucking fine.
Unfucking believable and just sit there and say that separate issues.
That's all tax issues.
That's all the same fucking issue.
Anyways.
Um,
you said it isn't fair that people being honest with their income have to pay
this rate.
Rich people hide their income overseas.
You also said tax money is being wasted on corporate corporate bullshit.
I agree with Paul.
Ira.
Read this,
this half a fucking paragraph that this person wrote.
You said we should pay politicians.
Fuck you money.
Uh,
you don't think if that happens,
even every money grubbing corrupt con will do anything possible to run for
office and win an election,
including promising corporation special deals and in exchange for campaigns.
So I do believe that.
I do believe that you've been saying this for years.
Yes.
I believe that.
I can't believe nobody's called you out on how fucking stupid it is,
dude.
You,
what's you're doing is you're basically going to be like this.
Well listen,
we can't get these guys,
so let's get the people we can get who haven't poisoned the food supply,
who don't,
who don't dictate our foreign policy.
Yeah.
Fuck all of that shit.
Fuck the $20 trillion sitting in the islands in the Caymans.
Let's go after the third baseman on the New York Yankees.
Yeah.
Fuck this guy.
This doesn't make any sense,
dude.
What could,
you can put a name and a face on that fucking guy and because he was better in
gym class than you,
you have this underlying resentment that you call him a poor,
poor millionaire.
Anyways,
he goes,
I think the biggest issue is that you come from comedy and you can't see beyond
that business.
I,
I seem to be talking about a bunch of businesses,
don't I?
I'm talking about our foreign policy.
I'm talking about the food supply.
Oh,
well how much further do I have to go?
I think everyone in this country should be in the position where their success
is measured by how hard they work and how much they contribute.
That is mostly true in comedy.
Dude.
First of all,
I'll throw you a hypocritical bolt.
I'm gonna.
I'll,
what the fuck do you know about comedy?
Right?
I know as much about comedy.
Is it,
I mean,
I know as much about your job as you know about comedy,
so why is your opinion on Comedians more valid
anyways?
If you are a millionaire and your daddy was a famous comedian,
notice how they use the word Daddy,
right?
That will only take you so far in comedy if you're not funny.
This is not true in every single business.
For example,
if Donald Trump had just invested his father's money in the stock market,
he would be Richard than he is now.
What the fuck is that based on?
Like what is the stock market guaranteed you're going to make money.
The stock market is corrupt,
but he is a very successful,
hardworking man deserving of all our empathy.
Just like every other rich asshole.
Yeah,
Dude.
You know what you have a problem with?
You have a problem with anybody who's rich cause you're all,
you're putting all of them.
You're using all the buzzwords.
Daddy,
rich,
asshole,
poor,
poor millionaire.
Anyways,
I graduated from Harvard in 2015 I'm a public school teacher.
One of the people you say tax money should be going towards yes.
Tax money that was already collected,
sir.
That was wasted on a neverending fucking war.
Yes,
yes.
But let's not go after the people that wasted that.
Let's take more tax dollars from somebody who fucking plays fucking power
forward for the fucking Cleveland Cavaliers anyways,
unlike my classmates making millions,
no matter how hard I work,
no matter how much time I spend on my students,
I don't earn another sent over my $48,000 salary.
Okay.
And did you not know that going into that fucking business?
Like what do,
what do you want me to do here?
I don't think you should earn that.
I think you should earn way more than that,
but I don't think that regular fucking people who don't stick their money in the
Cayman fucking islands are now required to pay for you because all these other
Americans are paying no taxes.
I,
I don't,
I don't feel that that's where that money should come from.
I feel that you should make way more money than that.
I think that you do one of the most important jobs in this country,
and I think you should get,
you should get paid,
I don't know,
200 fucking grand a year to do it.
And I think you should have all the supplies that you fucking need.
I 100.
I just don't agree with where you want to get that money.
He goes,
I can earn less than a thousand dollars in the next year pay.
I can't believe you're a fucking teacher by the way,
by the way,
you read,
you wrote this fucking thing,
but I'm going to,
I'm going to give you the benefit of the doubt and say that you were fucking
pissed off and fucking fired this thing off.
Or this is a giant voice text.
Um,
like an earn less than a thousand in the next year.
Pay Increase based on how my students do on statewide standardized text tests.
In fact,
if I want to spend money on class material,
it comes out of my own pocket,
can deduct a maximum of $250 a year.
Meanwhile,
some of the richest continents,
country are using their money to try and make public schools worse yet.
I've got to tell you something,
dude,
these aren't the guys you're going to get what that 70% tax thing.
And here's another thing,
dude.
Rather than call me a fucking dumb ass and a monkey hitting a fucking keyboard.
You know,
an idea that I had was I would like to,
as a
to do.
There's public schools in my fucking neighborhood here,
and I was walking by one the other day and I saw an auditorium and I'm thinking,
wait a minute,
they have an auditorium,
they got seats.
They've got to stage.
Why don't I do a fucking fundraiser for the public school?
That was my thought,
and I know I'm a mouth breather and fucking moron,
dude,
you and I are on the same fucking team here,
and we should not be fighting with each other.
We should be joining forces and demanding that these corrupt politicians go
after all the,
all these fucking asshole corporations and individuals who pay no taxes
rather than fucking as we're both like fucking trying to scamper out of the
boiling water point,
pulling each other down by each other's ankles.
All right,
but here's the funny fucking thing
is the second I've thought about doing that show,
all I thought was of the hashtags by the fucking parents and all of these
fucking lunatics whose minds have been poisoned by social media and all.
It's going to take his fucking one of them to go out there.
I can't do my fucking act in a public school auditorium in front of the fucking
parents.
How the fuck do I do that?
Yeah,
I know how I do it.
What I do is I get those cell phone bags and everybody has to put their fucking
cell phones in the fucking bag before you go in there.
That's how I'm going to have to end up doing it,
and unfortunately that's some of the money that I could have given that it could
have given back to the public school.
So here's the thing.
All right,
sir,
and I know you're not listening anymore.
I'm going to start doing those fucking shows.
I'm going to start doing shows.
I'm going to pick a fucking school and I'm going to give back that way,
that way.
I would rather do it that way.
Then eventually having to pay 60% fucking taxes on my income because I'm already
paying 56 that's just on my income.
That's not property tax.
That's not fucking,
uh,
um,
sales tax,
tax on gas is all these fucking hidden taxes done.
I'm already paying.
I'm lucky at this point,
if I'm keeping 30% of my fucking money,
I would cringe to see what the fuck I'm,
I'm,
I'm paying and fucking taxes and I know you have no sympathy for me cause I had
the audacity to have my fucking 300 to one fucking gray hound come across the
finish line and I won and that you fucking resent me for that,
you know,
and you lump me in to people and I'm not even at that fucking level.
All right?
But I've been around the block enough times to know that if that's 70% thing
gets fucking pass,
dude,
they're not going to stop at 10 and they're gonna keep going down.
So what I got out of this is,
you know something,
I'm going to do one of those fucking shows.
Um,
at the public schools and I'm going to start doing those fucking things and I'm
going to get,
I don't wanna get those fucking cell phone bags and I'll stick them in there.
And that's the way that I'm going to fucking give back.
And I'm gonna,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna get a positive out of this.
All right?
And I think what regular Americans need to do,
which is what I still am,
and you can fucking demonize me all you want because I'm the finally fucking
making money.
27 years into this fucking shit.
All right?
Where the fuck were you when I was sitting on the Futon,
waking up,
having panic attacks when I had no manager,
no fucking agent.
And all agents were telling me I had a weird look.
That's what he used to say to me.
By the way,
there is an unwritten rule in this fucking business that if you are a redhead,
you are not the lead in a movie.
Um,
I dunno if that's gradually changing,
but I remember I used to go to fucking auditions and like they would be prepared
three scenes.
It was back when I had a black and white photo.
So I kind of looked like I had brown hair.
It was in [inaudible] 90.
They had moose in there.
Oh right.
And I would come in as they looked at me,
I would see the look on their face.
They'd be like,
okay,
we're just going to read the first scene.
Yeah.
It's like,
dude,
you're red head and male.
You're not the lead.
You're the friend,
you're the friend.
You're the one who doesn't get the girl and all of that fucking shit.
Um,
so anyways,
we should be helping each other out,
sir.
Okay.
And here's the thing,
if I became a comedian and I didn't make it,
I wouldn't be crying to you about it.
Okay.
So you were the one who went to fucking Harvard and decided to become a public
school fucking teacher.
You knew what the deal was.
Okay.
That's what the fuck you wanted to do.
And I'm going to believe you that you went to Harvard and that you are a public
school teach.
Cause you know on the Internet people can be like,
I fucking,
I hate Trump.
And I'm a Republican.
People can do that all the fucking time.
I'm going to take all this face value and that you're actually a teacher and
that you wrote an email that was filled at this many spelling mistakes.
Um,
this,
this much fucking hypocritical behavior.
What you're yelling at me that I can't see past the end of my own nose.
I know the whole fucking thing was about you and your job and where the fuck you
sit in the world.
I didn't really see,
I didn't really see how you were.
You were,
um,
stepping outside of yourself.
Um,
so here's the thing,
sir,
or ma'am,
whoever fucking wrote this thing,
I'm going to start doing that.
All right?
I'm going to start doing fucking shows,
raising money for some,
for some fucking public,
uh,
I don't know,
high schools or whatever.
Get him some money for some computers or whatever.
And actually in a way I'd be helping myself cause I get a kid now and all the
public schools suck out here.
So now you got to go to private schools from the beginning,
you know,
and you're like hundreds of thousands of dollars down the fucking drain.
Because once again,
people who didn't pay taxes and all the money that all the money that we,
we've already bought,
the money that they already fucking collect does not go with a fuck.
It should be.
Um,
so I appreciate your input.
I hope you're mature enough to see,
you know,
I hope you don't decide not to keep listening to this podcast because of
something else because it sucks because it's not funny because it got boring to
you after awhile.
But if this is the reason why you're not listening,
you're,
you're a fucking baby.
You're a big fucking baby and you're really not solving the fucking problem.
Um,
and I think it's really ignorant to,
to demonize people that,
that made it on their own,
made it in a sport,
started a company,
you know,
but I draw the line at,
if you made it in a sport,
you don't pay taxes or you started a company and now that,
that your next move is to get your money outside the company.
I don't support that.
And if you're a comedian,
you need to do that.
I don't support that.
I don't,
I love Willie Nelson not paying taxes.
Don't support that.
Okay.
And I have no problem paying my fair share.
And I think at 56% plus all the others,
I think I'm more than doing it.
Unfortunately.
My tax money that I'm paying is getting nowhere near your school.
And that is not my fault,
but that is the problem.
And those are not separate issues from where I'm from.
All right.
That's the,
that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I,
I'm,
I'm gonna,
you know,
I'm going to make,
do on my,
my,
uh,
campaign promise.
I'm going to find a fucking school and I'm going to do it.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll see you on Thursday.